Miley Cyrus reveals the bizarre reason
why she stopped smoking weed remember
the last time I was here I think I was
dressed as like a bunny rabbit and
they're like a cat there's a reason for
that yeah hi Miley has been open about
her affinity for marijuana in the past
but it seems the 24-year old singer has
turned a new leaf here's what she told
Jimmy Fallon during her Tonight Show
appearance on Wednesday I had a dream
that I would die during my monologue on
SNL for some reason that I would just
get so stoned that I just like died we
were smoking a lot of weed it's like no
one's ever died from weed but no one's
ever smoked as much as I did
these days Miley is focused on her
upcoming album she performed her single
Malibu at the Billboard Awards in May
her younger sister Noah was on hand to
support I'm literally so proud of her
I'm getting all kind of emotional for
Miley cuz I'm really happy for her I'm
just so excited to be here with her and
like watch her perform cuz she was there
for me for like my first big like award
show and like I'm just like so excited
to like be here and like be able to give
it back to her
[Music]